Eric Boss here with another new  rockstars hot take I recently broke down  30 unanswered questions from Marvel  phase four that phase five really needs  to answer but the deepest one is about  free will after Loki and Ms Marvel and  She-Hulk does Free Will Truly exist in  the MCU well yes and no he remains  selected everything in the sacred  timeline he has a transcript of it but  he adapted that transcript he trimmed it  down from countless histories that  already existed long before him so the  Avengers made the choices they made  freely but other multiversal Avengers  were denied that privilege so the  infinity Saga Avengers had free will but  only thanks to their multiversal  privilege so the whole Free Will  question really comes back to you do you  have the life that you have because of  your choices or because of your  circumstances a bit of both right